no character is safe on the walking dead
while every death is impactful in its
own way there have been a number of
characters whose ends stand out
against the show's many others these are
the saddest deaths
that have happened on the walking dead
season one of the walking dead proves
from the beginning that the story takes
place in an
unforgiving world however with only six
episodes
no single death in this inaugural season
is all that impactful
by the time season 2 rolls around though
viewers have had the time to get to know
the characters
as a result when carol experiences the
worst loss
a mother can imagine it carries
considerable weight
when the group leaves the cdc at the end
of season 1
their rv gets stuck on a jammed highway
just as a herd of walkers passes through
carol's daughter sophia hides under the
cars with the rest of the group but
emerges too quickly
and is chased into the woods by walkers
rick finds her and tells her to hide
while he lures them away but when he
returns
she's gone the group launches an
impressive search effort given their
resources
using herschel green's farm as a base of
operations
however it is soon revealed that
herschel was locking walkers up in his
barn rather than killing them when shane
snaps and decides to execute all of
herschel's captive walkers it's revealed
that sofia didn't escape the woods with
her life
she is one of the pent-up undead this
forces rick to mercy kill her an act
that forever hardens carol
into the character we know and love
today
shane proves to be a reluctant ally to
rick although they were once friends he
spends most of season 2
poking the proverbial bear until what's
left of the world
still isn't big enough for the both of
them shane hatches a clever plot that
sees him
execute the group's first ever prisoner
he beats his own face on a tree to make
it look like the prisoner escaped then
embarks on a surge
with rick it soon becomes clear that
shane means to kill
rick and frame the dead prisoner for the
crime unfortunately he feels that he
owes his old partner a monologue about
fatherhood
and survival allowing rick to appear
like he's given up
before he surprises shane with a blade
to the gut this is one of the saddest
deaths in the show thus far because it
forces the audience to say goodbye to a
character who's been around from the
very beginning
as shane dies in rick's arms rick can't
stop repeating that this is all shane's
fault
as though he's trying to convince
himself of this more than his old
partner
shane's story ends after he's reanimated
as a walker and makes his way toward
rick
forcing carl to kill him for good
lori grimes is a controversial character
and the walking dead fandom
when we're introduced to her she's
already moved on from rick to his best
friend shane
when rick unexpectedly returns she is
distant with him because she knows that
the baby she's pregnant with could be
either his
or shane's season three sees her story
come to a tragic end
when a rogue prisoner unleashes a horde
of walkers on the only true
safe haven our heroes have found lori
carl
and maggie find themselves trapped in a
boiler room the pursuit causes lori to
go into labor
she begins to hemorrhage and has to make
the tough call to have a c-section that
will undoubtedly kill her
but spare the baby she goes through with
it without hesitation and sadly the
worst happens
she bids one last farewell to her son
telling him that he's going to beat this
world
when it's over carl insists on being the
one to kill his mother so she doesn't
turn
he brings the good news of the baby and
the bad news of his mom's death to rick
all at the same time rick rushes back
into the prison to find a walker has
ghoulishly devoured what was left of his
wife
merle is a miserable virulent racist
jerk who still manages to have one of
the show's saddest deaths
after he gets handcuffed to a rooftop in
atlanta by rick grimes he manages to
escape by cutting off part of his arm he
makes his way to woodbury where he
becomes the governor's right-hand man
pun absolutely intended if merle has a
soft spot
it's for his little brother daryl who by
the time the reunited is a loyal member
of
rick's group although merle makes a
brief attempt to run off with his
brother he quickly realizes that daryl
is not the man he once was
resenting his brother's newfound
goodness merle tries to prove that his
way of thinking
is what's going to get the job done in
the fight against the governor
and launches an assassination attempt
however a rogue walker interrupts his
attack
and the governor takes his shot tearing
off two of merle's remaining fingers and
breaking his other arm
merle not surprisingly has some defiant
last words
i ain't gonna i ain't begging you
no daryl catches up to the scene too
late
after seeing his older brother as a
walker daryl crumbles
then puts him down in an explosion of
righteous frustration after becoming a
wandering vagrant the governor finds
himself a new faction of loyal soldiers
and launches another attack
on rick's prison which now houses the
former residents of woodbury while
scouting the area the governor spots
herschel and michonne disposing of
walker corpses outside the walls
he takes them both captive and uses them
as leverage to get rick to surrender the
prison
after giving an impassioned speech about
the former members of woodbury now
living in peace
rick invites the governor to put war
aside and join them but the governor has
been driven mad by the events of the
apocalypse and his hatred for rick
he refuses and cuts off herschel's head
with michonne's katana
the moment is raw and the helplessness
and dread of the group boils over
unfortunately considering the state of
the world things don't end
here the next episode opens with
herschel's severed head desperately
gnashing its teeth hoping for human
flesh he's finally put
down for good by michonne's katana this
time wielded by its proper owner in an
act
of mercy lizzie and mika are first
introduced after the prison survivors
take in woodbury residents
their mother has died and turned into a
walker and their father dies shortly
after they arrive at the prison
with both her parents dead and a little
sister now looking to her for guidance
lizzy suits herself by reasoning that
walkers are just another form of
humanity
after the prison falls to the governor's
attack lizzie demonstrates a reluctance
to let the adults around her kill
walkers
soon she starts actually feeding walkers
and attempting to play games like tag
with them
she and carol began to argue over
whether or not walkers are dangerous as
she's convinced herself that they're
just hungry
and that one can make friends with them
to prove her point she kills her little
sister mika the second they're alone
together
convinced mika will come back and won't
try to hurt them she explains that she
plans to do the same thing to baby
judith
this is the final stroll for carol she
quietly takes lizzie into an open field
and tricks her
into turning her back knowing that it's
the only way to keep
judith tyrese and herself alive on the
harsh road
carol executes lizzie while tyrese deals
with her reanimated sister
first introduced in season 4 abraham
endears himself to the rest of the group
pretty quickly once it becomes apparent
that he's a tremendous fighter
by the time the group makes its way to
alexandria abraham is just starting to
find himself as a person in civilized
society for perhaps the first time in
his life
naturally this is when he dies a death
that introduces the unforgettable negan
after taking on an outpost run by his
group the saviors negan prevents our
heroes from making their way to the
hilltop colony to provide maggie with
some much needed medical attention
the group is forced out of their rv
where the saviors surround them negan
finally reveals himself and explains
that they all now work for him
he also tells them that someone has to
die for their crimes against the saviors
thus far
and what became one of the biggest
cliffhangers in the show's history
fans were forced to wait until the
season 7 premiere to find out who would
lose negan's sinister game of eenie
meenie miney moe
it turns out to be abraham who negan
beats to death with his signature
baseball bat
oh look at that taking it like a champ
as the others watch helplessly in horror
negan swings until there is nothing left
[Applause]
glenn's life looks bright even in the
midst of armageddon he survives the
onset of the apocalypse
the farm the prison woodbury terminus
the attacks on alexandria and the first
clash with the saviors
he goes on to marry maggie green and
they end up with a baby on the way
this is why the utterly unceremonious
nature of his death hits so close to
home
after brutally beating abraham negan
monologues a bit too much
when he gets in rosita's face daryl has
had enough
he gets up from his knees and gives
negan a rock solid punch in the face
this obviously doesn't sit well with
negan given the fact that this entire
demonstration is designed to prove his
dominance
rather than bludgeon daryl negan proves
his instability further by bashing
glenn's head
dazed and on the brink of death his last
words are to maggie who can't even look
at his grotesque skull
maggie i'll find you he promises
implying that he'll be looking for her
in the afterlife when she gets there
with that negan finishes his gruesome
work if this list were a ranking glenn's
death would undoubtedly be our pick for
the saddest one of
all carl grimes starts as a helpless kid
however the apocalypse hardens him the
same as any other venerable survivor
sure he has his adolescent moments in
which he eats too much pudding or reads
too many comic books but overall he's a
bona fide warrior he even loses an
eye eventually the war with negan causes
carl to
realize that although he's killed people
himself a better way to live one's life
exists that's why when he sees a man
named siddique wandering the woods
about to be consumed by a herd of
walkers he steps in and helps save his
life
unfortunately the bout results in carl
getting bit in the abdomen
realizing his fate carl writes letters
to his loved ones and prepares for the
end
he even manages to lead the alexandrian
survivors
adults and all to safety during a
surprise attack by negan
and the saviors once everyone is
somewhat safe carl reveals his wound to
his dad and michonne
and uses his final words to advocate for
a better world
free of war as his mom told him with her
final breaths
carl is the one with a hope of beating
this world by sacrificing himself for
his fellow man
he does after nearly a decade of peace
the survivors find themselves at odds
with yet another faction
the whisperers daryl and company kidnap
their leader alpha's daughter
lydia at first she's reluctant to join
their group of survivors
but relents once daryl realizes that
she's being abused and is able to relate
to her alpha hatches a plot to kidnap
several of the survivors responsible
just when it seems like she's going to
execute them negan style
she explains that her desire is to get
her daughter back
and for them to respect a border between
their peoples
i wanted to kill them but i want my
daughter more
she shows daryl a herd of zombies and
tells them that she'll unleash them on
the kingdom
the hilltop and alexandria if they
violate this border
to mark the border it's revealed that
alpha captured a handful of hilltop
survivors
including tara and the youngsters henry
and enid
in a brazen power play she decapitated
all of them
and has put their heads on spikes to
mark the area
where daryl and the survivors are never
ever to cross
to make matters worse the heads have
reanimated
in a world that lives on hope alone
alpha's decision to execute some of the
colony's youngest
and most promising survivors is a
devastating blow
youth often doesn't last long in the
zombie apocalypse
beth green begins her journey as a young
girl dating a boy she likes from around
town
when the apocalypse hits their farm is
quickly overrun
setting beth and her remaining family
members on a journey throughout the
harsh world that remained
she survives horrors that no one her age
should ever have to
such as the loss of her family two
boyfriends and countless friends
just as she's learning to deal with loss
and become a useful figure for her
community
the final thing she has to lose is taken
from her
freedom beth is kidnapped and brought to
a hospital where a police officer named
dawn holds a loose command over the
patients
and cops living there beth calls that
power into question when she helps a man
named noah
escape eventually rick and the gang
fined beth and managed to capture two of
dawn's people
in order to negotiate a prisoner
exchange unfortunately
dawn seizes that moment to flex her
muscle and demand noah be returned
the task is simply a bridge too far for
beth she cleverly approaches dawn for a
final goodbye
and stabs her shoulder reflexively don
fires a shot into beth's head
at close range killing her thanks to
beth's sacrifice
noah is allowed to finally be free of
his captivity from the hospital
survivors
he joins up with rick's group and
immediately becomes a useful member
of the team he even manages to make it
with them all the way to the improbable
alexandria safe haven there he requests
to learn architecture so he can further
keep the place safe for future
generations
as part of his propensity to be one of
the most helpful people around he
accompanies glenn
eugene tara and two of alexandria's most
inept runners aiden and nicholas
as they look for supplies to make
alexandria's power grid better on the
run
aiden encounters a soldier that has
turned and attempts to shoot him
in a stroke of bad luck he ends up
hitting a grenade and causes an
explosion that leaves him impaled on
some metal
rather than help nicholas flees the
scene as walkers descend
and he noah and glenn get trapped in a
revolving door on their way out of the
building
though glenn cautions them not to panic
nicholas does
anyway selfishly turning the door so he
can escape
and the walker surrounding them can get
at noah and what is by far the most
gruesome death of the entire series
glenn watches helplessly as dozens of
walkers literally tear noah to pieces
and devour him
taking a life of potential and beth's
ultimate sacrifice
with them one of the more consequential
figures in rick rime's early war with
the notorious governor
is andrea she begins the series as one
of the people shane helps escape atlanta
following the death of her sister
andrea's main journey is one of a woman
who refuses to ever be helpless again
after the green farm is overrun she and
michonne make their way to woodbury
where the governor rules with an iron
fist
unafraid andrea begins a relationship
with him and even finds herself among
his most trusted generals
however she quickly realizes that she
bet on the wrong horse as his madness
and
utter contempt for human life starts to
show she realizes that he is the villain
of the story
and begins taking steps to allow rick to
win including leaving woodbury and
warning of an impending attack
unfortunately the governor personally
tracks her down
although she puts up quite a fight his
relentless mania is too much for her
he knocks her out and drags her back to
his torture room in woodbury where he
orders her ally in the escape milton to
execute her
he refuses prompting the governor to
kill him and allow him to reanimate
alone in a room with andrea
she is bitten and subsequently requests
a pistol from rick to end things
on her own terms tyrese is the group's
resident gentle giant before his tragic
and untimely death though he suffers
numerous tragedies throughout his tenure
it never once dampens his ability to
save the people around him
viewers got an explanation for tyrese's
extremely empathetic and emotional state
during his final episode when he reveals
that his father would make him listen to
the news
at a young age so he would never be
unaware of the atrocities in the world
he lives with the bad in the world but
he never forgets about it
tyrese dies while accompanying glenn
rick
michonne and noah on a trip to noah's
family home
unfortunately they find the place has
fallen and noah's family
is dead while there one of noah's
reanimated brothers emerges out of
nowhere and bites tyrese on the arm
noah goes for help and tyrese lays on
the floor bleeding
hallucinating both the people he saved
and the people he hurt
although the survivors are able to
amputate he's lost too much blood and
succumbs to his wounds
thankfully he accepts his fate before
the end reasoning out with his
hallucinations that death is no true
sadness for an empathetic person like
him
compared to the harsh world humanity now
lives in
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the walking dead are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one